فيجتمعوا وزراء الطاقه في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بروكسل اليوم في محاوله
للاتفاق على حد اقصى لاسعار الغاز في احدث
خطوه للتغلب على ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا
والناجمه عن الحرب في اوكرانيا ورغم
الشهور من المفاوضات وعقد اجتماعين
وزاريين طارئين حول مقترح الاتحاد
الاوروبي لوضع سقف للسعر لم تتواصل الدول
لاتفاق بشانه كما انها تختلف في ما بينها
حول مائده كان يمكن ان يخفف من ازمه
الطاقه في اوروبا او سيوفاقمها ومنذ
انقطعت موسكو غالبيه الغاز الذي كانت
ترسله الى اوروبا توجه الدول الاوروبيه
ارتفاعا غير مسبوق في الاسعار ما دفع
التضخم الى مستويات قياسيه بناء عليه وضعت
التشيك التي تتولى الرئاسه الدوريه
للاتحاد الاوروبي مسوده اتفاقا جديد في
محاوله لكسر الجنود الحالي وتؤكد الدول
المؤيده لفرد سقف لاسعار الغاز ان الحد
الاقصى يجب ان يكون دون المئتي لكل
ميغاوات في الساعه حتى يفلح في التعامل مع
ارتفاع اسعار الغاز الذي تسبب في ارتفاع
فواتير المستهلكين وكاله بلومبرج لافتات
الى ان خطه التدخل في السوق التي كشفت
عنها المفوضيه الاوروبيه الشهر الماضي
تسببت في خلافات عميقه بين الاعضاء موضحه
ان بعض الدول على راسها المانيا وهولندا
والدنمارك تدعو الى نهج حذر بينما تضغط
مجموعه اخرى تضم بلجيكا وايطاليا واليونان
وبولندا لاستخدام ادوات اكثر فاعليه
للسيطره على اسعار الغاز يشكك بعض
الدبلوماسيين في امكانيه التوصل الى اتفاق
هذا الاسبوع 10 الى ان الدول غير الراضيه
عن الاقتراح الاحدث لديها ما يكفي من
الدعم لمنع الموافقه عليه